I'm not looking for anything
[Music]
pure
this is the best basketball player basketball player
I would say of course because of course you but
secondly another would say little he plays well he
likes to do the skills and so
and as he is tall we have sometimes played
games between the two of us and sometimes
to the cattle  it is the winner but he would say
and the number 10 points 18 17
[Music]
almost so he is close but yes but
not at my different level I am there
[Music]
ah
not
the first time to enter the
field and  the emotions I, well, very
impressed with my eyes wide open and
in the locker room they have welcomed me very well
and of course they are players who are very good
and whom I have a lot of respect for then
[Music]
k seconds
and I
[Music]
or
[Music  ]
e
[Music]
and I believed in the club as a personal
dream all year long, it says champions this
year the functions of for the champions
for me it is the objective the challenge of the
champions we also have the Eurocup at the
end it is in the summer then and for  me is
a dream because I have never won the
champions so to win here I
think the club wants and needs it and so do I
[Music]
here